all right less than ten here we go
warzone Kings one-minute war zone raided
51 players 1783 average rating time
handicapped here we go look at the clock
it's already messed up it's saying okay
now it's back come on you fire this up
here we go I took a little bit there
come on now can I get a quicker win here
can we get a quicker win oh let's take
care Smith Morra
decline tempo gainer tempo gain around
the Queen it might be happening there it
is Queen right here you know you want to
play Queen right here still fishing
fishing fishing is the night really
gonna move ah
sneaky nights whoa I almost dropped my
queen let's not drop the Queen please
whatever you do do not drop the Queen
get out of here light square
weaknesses light square weaknesses Oh
Queen check let's get this pawn break at
the pond queenside castle now here come
here before it's too late
I'm on the night oh they must be scared
get out of there Knight you have no
business being there no business Queen
check Queen block I grab the pawn this
pawn is crumbling they're gonna get this
but I have this
wait a second let's give a check not
sure why no that's a good move
okay let's just take the game's not
gonna end I'm up pon I'm up a piece
let's come back here oh I should have
just given a check let's come here
they're down untie him back to chairman
two's
everybody has it two strikers up there
he was right up there in the top three
in that last game ah I have to remember
to go with the fantasy variation against
the Carroll alright Bishop takes I am
stop castling no castling watch over d4
make up your mind bishop
it's Castle look on a half-open file I'm
gonna go for it
bishops dead then they can't open up my
Kings side because my bishop being right
there pawn push I guess actually I'm
gonna take I like having my [ __ ] in my
on my bishop I look right there even
though there is this I have that keep it
closed
ooh it's gonna be a bit dangerous a
little bit dangerous here if the Queen
give a check bump up guard my knight I
think everything is okay I think that's
the key word right there and check I'm
on the roof twice pigs got to take the
Queen otherwise it's gonna be mate made
on b7 they resigned back to tournament
six five five that was a quick win okay
26 and change
let's roll here c5 let's do it c5 grab
that open Sicilian protect my clean
this is not complete like this is not am
I trying to say
just one minute like a one-minute setup
this is actually like a pretty good
setup to an extent here
oh now am I gonna be getting this night
by force I'm getting a piece by force
now yeah this is trouble
weaknesses on the dark squares
I might resign they resigned back to
tournament twelve six six six
okay twelve a bunch of sixes a couple
fives a couple threes Andy Andy here we
go this is what I wanted to be doing
here now let's get in
maybe this move I'm gonna no no no Queen
b6 is probably good in those
complications
not if I brought my knight out instead
of my bishop there was Bishop g4 that's
why I went with this instead of Knight
f3
okay I've discovered enough and my
Queens watching over that we're here
what's the pawn break I don't know just
kick this night away and then get at the
Queen discovered tricks I want to get
rid of discovered trick I want to get
rid of the dark square Bishop and then
get to these squares Queen here Queen
here let's give a check my knight can
move with tempo on the Queen
this is winning some material discovered
check happening fork happening let's
back up this is still a threat I want to
break here Forks Queen Queen's come off
I get the night I got a piece at the end
of this I hear post up a knight folks
are coming off the brook is hit twice
oh my lip or there are no take-backs in
this tournament Forks oh everything's
falling now back to tournament 20 2012
11 11
less than 25 c5
alright let's shut that Bishop down
let's look to kick it away it's being
kicked away it cannot go back gets
killed if it goes back pawn isn't a pin
I might want to do this let's go for it
pile up on this pond kick the night away
the queen is dead let's get to this
square maybe right here don't repair
that Knights or the pawn structure clean
here I'm on this pawn with check kick
the night away here it defends the
bishop though you know it's it's not too
bad
well let's see if it goes there I guess
it has to go there all Forks we can get
out of that though with the check Oh
everything's hit rook and Knight let's
get rid of that checks here I'm on the
rook okay I'm on the bishop as well
cannot be defended and now right here
right here where's the mate
main threat light squares where is the
mate pawn push capture pawn pushes mate
pawn push or captured pawn pushes mate
they're down on time anything I'm just
gonna go here in case there's a knight
check back to tournament thirty twenty
twenty twenty two minutes okay who's on
my heels who's this guy friend or we got
the French X the future we've played
before I think pressure on this pawn my
knight is pinned let's break this pin
throw a question to that bishop okay
that's gonna happen isn't it that's
gonna happen isn't it you know I get
this pawn cuz I have this supported even
if there's a c5 strike yeah I'm getting
this pun okay let's castle let's try
again
alright we're gonna have a bunch of
trades and I want to stop this Bishop
from observing this square and I need to
get my Bishop doing something else I
want my Bishop on e5 let's get to e5
well I don't know if I should have done
that let's make this pawn flinch let's
go here I want to play Bishop d4 oh hang
on this is a bit scary over here oh man
let's do this I don't want to take here
cuz of um some sacks on this square I
need more support for that I think I'm
on the rook I got to stop this advance
oh I would have been bad can I take this
pawn and get away with it I think I can
now 16 seconds I want to Queen trade
pawn push might be good now I'll have
this with the Czech Queen trade let's go
for a queen trade over here now
Queen trade
Queen takes pawn huh no no no no no
don't fall for me
don't fall for me defend defend defend
defend defend everything oh you're not
defending everything oh no no no no I
just shot my queen
I'm gonna drop my queen come back here
oh no no no no no no no defend defend oh
come over here
defend what does that we'll even do
their damage I'll take it oh sorry I got
loud again
I got loud again sorry there's nothing I
could do you just have to be you have to
be afraid I didn't mean to say that you
have to be afraid what does that even
mean I'm not gonna listen anymore if I'm
gonna have to be afraid they're saying
if you forgive me I just I just don't
know what I'm saying when I'm playing
these games it's tough it's tough when
you're down in time just never know you
never know what's gonna happen
Oh Queen is his she gonna move Queen
here LightScribe bishops off b5
expansion let's expand some more let's
hit the Queen a bit more maybe even
again having some fun Queens getting
kicked around she can't be too happy
can't she let's go I'm on this pond it's
dropped night here forks forks might be
a rook capture first alright let's take
this and then Oh an in-betweener but I'm
netting a full rook now that is a full
rook I'm on the Queen as well they
missed it they might have worries they
might have a resign but they might
resign they resigned back to term in 56
30 30 missed in e4 less than 19 minutes
remaining
all right French French defense f4 build
the center c5 reinforced d4 I'm gonna
take that pun let's just guard it I
don't know if that's best it's probably
not best I should just queenside castle
now queenside castle might be a pawn
push so let's not do that I support my
pawn
okay I have to give up that now I could
get an f5 though maybe let's do this I
was fearful of Bishop there let's do
this now I want to keep the Queen's on
the board and back up to home so let's
do this now Bishop here I was gonna come
back if I did that right away
alright let's break this up if I did
that right away there would have been a
bishop type of move the bishop type of
move what do I want to do my knight
would like to be right here I guess
their king is a bit safe I wanted Queen
g5 in know there's two things going on
Bishop takes Knight was trying to and
Queen takes pawn 33 seconds I want to I
want to capture that pawn that's what
I'm gonna threaten Knight takes pawn
here it's got to be good right oh let's
try this first whoa
oh no no no no no no no no no I'm in a
nasty pin get out of the pen
what's the clock situation oh I got a
pod okay I'm gonna give black some
problems now rook here grab the other
pond right give a check grab another
pond okay everything is okay now King
out looking up again oh I could have
taken the rook
they were pretty moving let's go up on
Oh mate until me - one two back to
tournament 72-42 forty 16 minutes and
change
here's the clock well you could still
see it in the stream here we go already
let's go let's roll here I'm not gonna
come out he is coming out
hi g4 what are they doing this is like a
reverse fishing pole maybe five just
Castle here we go it's happening before
it will happen again
confident about that I'm confident about
it move nothing power of suggestion H -
oh man H - H - H - huh that's the most
popular square in the chessboard I tell
you fishing pole when you think about
the fishing pole you might as well just
start thinking about H 2 or H 7 pick
your favorite Bishop III queen d to get
rid of the dark square Bishop and things
are fun against the Kings side looking
for the fun positions here here we go my
light square bishop would like to play
but let's hit the Queen I'm on the night
let's keep this guy away grab here whoa
something gonna happen here that's bad
maybe can I get away with this Queen
takes pawn
let's go here haha take a pit stop right
there I should thrown into check first
what are you doing
defend a pond I think it should still be
okay but I should have thrown in a check
ah I got trade Queens it's too scary
yeah they are clean get out of there
let's get rid of him two opposite
colored bishops I don't have any time
whoa where'd my clock go what does this
move even do what does that move even do
I don't even know king position though
hang on come over here can I get this
pawn rolling I'm gonna move one of their
pawns I'm not afraid of the rooks am i
oh wonderful questions everywhere I ask
really good questions don't get mated
whatever you do whoa I'm not in the pin
my king is run crazy yeah all right I'm
okay with giving up a rook just take
that so my defense is easier you have
this pawn what's the count
what's the count they're moving fast oh
I got this run pons pons on dark where's
the mate matin to pawn or bishop they
have a pawn that they can move back to
tournament one 1000 running away run
away from the pack Oh how many times do
I have to tell myself not to capture
there in these one-minute games ah man
it's better to keep the tension there
alright let's no Mouse slip mouse slip
Mouse lip okay
the Knights gonna be annoying isn't he
and stop it my knight wants to be on f5
this is a perfect home the bishop wants
to be here my pawn wants to be up my
other Knight wants to be on c4 what's
going on here pawn push that might be
good defend Queen
now take it no it's still not good
okay the queens are coming off if Queen
takes pawn otherwise King f7 everything
is good oh this is uh this is fine here
can't break this down Queen c7 I'm on
the night in the Queen I have a file
let's bump up I don't want the night to
come here although who came here it was
alright should just piled up here right
away
this pond cannot be defended good
premium of that no matter what a bunch
of checks get that night twice night's
pin that's hit twice defended zero it's
gonna be taken with check this nights
gonna follow the rook is gonna fall
check still the same story pin the rook
is ready to fall oh she's just taking
that I wasn't expecting it where's the
mate one two three four
no can't go there back to tournament 130
130 72 sandy is in second oh we have a
quick resigning 140 William B William B
well that was almost an accelerated
Sicilian right there c4 move one C for
Sicilian William B I'm sure is well well
aware of the fish pool he's just not
gonna Castle he's gonna show me Oh how's
waking to defend okay it does weaken the
light squares though I can do this it's
gonna be Bishop takes watch out for
tricky bishop moves mom is twice light
square weaknesses light squares
uh-oh light squares let's do this clean
here next I'm on the knight twice if he
moves it's me
oh I don't want to trade Queens I'm
gonna play here and get rid of the
knight forks forks made on g2 okay I'm
getting a piece out of this back ranks
just support my bishop nice pawn chain
just take this sneak my king up rook
takes pawn threatened leading to me just
want to watch over g3 so there's this
mate coming up mate on h1 the rook has
to block on h5 I guess is the only other
computer to computer like delaying move
one sixty ninety okay
CIN CIN CIN CIN all right
[ __ ] this go with the small pawn Center
and in the meantime we have that guard
this stop the h-file from opening up
let's get at this pond now with Czech
Kings running scared reinforce this pond
complete my development queenside castle
night here open up this diagonal towards
the king kill this night it's back up
hang on this taken time out for a second
there I thought Queen get so active
wanna hang on to this I want to pinpoint
that pond get out of there Bishop pond
push is fine darn it why they moving so
fast I'm in check that's probably not a
good idea and get that the Queen's gonna
take the pond I want to get at that
Bishop I'm gonna hit it a bunch of times
it's not going anywhere though I can't
take no I could take the rook though I
could take the bishop uh-oh ah this is
crumbling now mate in 1 2 3
no not so fast now it is back determine
180 no yes
180 110 106 less than 8 minutes
remaining nap this is another guy that
is well aware of the little line that I
end up casting here they're not gonna
move Knapp is not moving uh-oh let's see
what's going on elsewhere leaders sandy
is that one I have 200 130
Oh what happened here what happened
what's happening here that guy resign he
must resigned that's why I had 200 oh
that guy resigned I didn't get to see it
but he resigned oh man give me that H
file uh-oh
giant thorn alert on h6 oh and a
difficult pin to get out of this is
there's no good solution here the
Queen's dead Queen to g4 get the Queen
on g4 and everything is fine actually
there's a maintenance a 220 140 less
than seven mini
Minnie here all right let's go with this
Queen c7 get this Night Out Knight f6
captured towards the sound unless you
have a good reason not to force the fish
o at all costs and all costs each file
it's clearly being defended easily now I
have nothing
I actually actually do a pawn push and
capture in this direction whoa let's
keep it closed dropping that pun it's
not so great
what's the story here whoa I got to get
rid that night he's a bad man he is one
bad man let me tell you um let's go here
whoa this is scary
haha I just wanna Queen trade please
please please
Queen trade there's gonna be checks and
stuff isn't there there's no good checks
is this working
I'm on the Queen only 15 seconds I'm on
the bishop with check can I save this I
gotta get it rid of that thorn huh
that's leading to me that's a self-made
why'd I move my king oh man my king like
that I was a giant thorn there was a
giant thorn right there I walked right
into the thorn oh did that hurt man
avoid those thorns man playing on tilt
playing on tilt now man did that sting I
am wounded right now
man everybody hates a mate in 1 or 2 man
can I get rid of a piece here oh man hit
a rock get on c7 maybe make it one pawn
push aah
what a tough thorn can I get just give
up at night and somehow get me man the
fishing pole does not always work be
aware of that it does not always work
sometimes it works against you
Knight takes pawn might be a threat oh
this is working no it's not a threat the
Queen is protected silly
oh no more bad calculation I need time
burners where are the time burners when
you need them where are they when you
need them sit a knight
it's come here Oh time burners is what I
need well I'm getting a piece back I was
down to pieces there is give a check
defend stuff where are the time burners
where are they they're gonna play here
no they're not give a check I need to
hang on to my last the last piece let's
give a check no no no the rook might
have blocked right there oh oh that
could have been bad I don't have any
time I'm gonna get mated
they're coming humming OH just I should
have lost that one whoa I might not win
I know I'm gonna win still right am i I
have to beat the black ninja though
black ninja 12 is here ah I'm not gonna
win on this guy he's gonna have
something to say about it and oh don't
even look over here it's a site for oh
don't even look don't look over here
it's bad news a lot of holes going on
over here
morals everywhere Wow everybody loves
double double isolated pawns oh man
let's go
this pond is actually serving a decent
role though let's get out get that night
out of there would you get out of there
whoa give a check come on here and take
that guy oh I got a rock out of it let's
go King you know your home is on f6 you
know your home is on f6 let's get rid of
that i undoes pawns but it should be
okay right let's go my rook wants
activity oh just take a free pawn if
it's free take a free pawn if it's free
take another one it's now past past pond
oh what's happening here
stop the rook activity run pollen get
behind the past pond push it away
rook g1 I get that guy and this one
where's the mate don't allow stalemate
King here let's come all the way over
here check check let's try this one I'm
gonna sneak over on the other side now
oh they're letting their clock tick
don't do that ninja
Oh ninja don't do that just resign
ah man okay here we go
dr. Turman 2:58 I'm still gonna get it
but not without that scar that thorn
I've been formed oh man I was so painful
it really was it does have that impact
on me
I like fun for me of course who does who
does like Fong for me all right
Oh first-place confetti okay ah good
games ah
258 221 86